Tanner its Ross Tucker filling in for
Dan today really appreciate your time
thanks for coming on the show and thanks
Roz good to be with you
I guess I just want to start with how
you got into politics I mean your before
we get into Gordon Hayward stuff
obviously your dad's in basketball your
brothers in basketball how did you how
did you enter the political arena or
decide to you know it's probably because
I'm the worst at my brothers and so you
know I I didn't have that path to
continue and so I went to the business
world I've been in the business world
for the for the past decade or so and
helping businesses grow and and I like
they followed the direction of the
country and the way we're going you know
sometimes I complain I wish I could make
a difference and and you know for people
on a national not be aware but Utah free
is 10 we're going to put you on hold
real quick and see if we can get you a
better line you're sound like your cell
reception is going in and out Canada can
you hear us a little bit better now I
got a better line yeah sorry about that
Ross yeah no problem sure where you lost
me yeah you were you were just saying
you know I just said everybody in your
family it seems like is in basketball
other than you I was just curious as to
to why how did you get into politics
yeah well I started to say that it's
probably because I'm the worst athlete
of my brothers and so I had to find a
different path and and my path wasn't
really politics it's been in the
business world where I've spent the last
decade helping to invest in and build
companies but you know like like many
listeners I see the direction our
country's going in and and I don't
always want to be on the sidelines I
want to get in and try to make a
difference and you know national
listeners might not know but in Utah and
our district congressman Chaffetz
stepped down in the middle of his term
and so there's this very short window
special election and so I decided this
is this is my my time to get off the
sidelines what was it like being the
worst athlete the family
well hey it was still competitive right
I mean I it's not it wasn't worse by a
mile but so we had we had a lot of time
to have some some battles mainly with
Austin my older brother the other two
are quite a bit younger than me so I
always owned them yeah
nice all right well let's let's get into
your tweet and and what's going on my
question is who's your favorite
basketball team well look what's nice
about the the Hayward situation right
now is that Austin and my dad can't
really talk about free agency at the
moment but I can and I'm trying to
represent the 3rd District of Utah and
so I don't I don't see why why he should
leave I mean Ross have you been out to
Utah you know we're down for our Tanner
I have been a couple of times every
other year we go skiing in Deer Valley
and it is amazing I always say right if
I couldn't live in Pennsylvania my next
stop would be Wisconsin just because of
the four food groups that those people
have cheese fears brats but then after
that it would be Salt Lake City man if
anybody listening has ever been there it
is unmoving I heard Tanner I've never
been there but I've heard it's even
better in the summer exactly in the
summer we've got the Green Mountains you
can fish you can hike you mountain bike
it is there's no better place to be and
you know on top of that I highlighted
the tax issue here we've got lower taxes
than you would have in Massachusetts and
and you know Hayward is actually an
inspiring computer engineer and right
now Utah's economy we've got a whole new
tech corridor that's thriving it's known
as the silicon slope out here so look I
don't know why he'd want to leave so uh
you know what was great about that
answer Tanner is that you've gotten off
to a good start with your political
career because you didn't actually
answer who your favorite team was to the
wrong hands why Gordon shouldn't leave
but you didn't really say the Jazz are
your favorite team and not the Celtics
well you know my dad might one thing I
learned from my dad
is and of course I love them and support
them he's my hero and you know in sports
when you're in it you know this you
build relationships with people and so
while many of us being across the
country you cheer for where you're from
when you've jumped around to so many
teams and you've played with players you
know you cheer for people just as much
and so look I always want my dad and my
brother to be successful more my brother
my dad's already had enough success I'm
cheering for Austin to be successful but
yeah I'm also I want Heyward to say in
Utah and I don't I don't understand why
anyone would want to leave our district
so give me your give me your best pitch
like pretend I'm Gordon Hayward and you
get me on the phone I'm like look Tanner
I mean a chance to play for the Miami
Heat with Pat Riley and Spoelstra and
there's no state income tax down there
in Florida or the Celtics you know think
about the tradition and the legends of
the Celtics they have an awesome guy at
the head of the organization named Danny
Ainge and they got a team that maybe if
I go there we might be able to win the
NBA championship or at least compete
with the Cavaliers why why should I stay
in Utah because of all the reasons we
said one you want to live here you're
going to make more more money here in
Utah you're already in a great role
you've been thriving you're going to
continue to thrive you've got Rudy
Gobert to play alongside and you know
but more importantly people in Utah
want their players to stay you know we
need to get back to the days where you
know what's stopped in him alone when
the Jazz were actually competing in the
finals and and those guys who did that
the the people of Utah will always
remember them they're kind of chiseled
on the mountains here and so Hayward has
an opportunity here in Utah to be he's
the number one guy there's no other
professional sports team
we don't have an NFL team we don't have
a major league baseball team and so this
is he's the guy in a market that's
rising and it's a great place to live
for all the reasons we've gone through
when's the election
the election is August 15th and by the
way since you asked that I've got to get
my plug in so anyone who's interested go
to wwas for congress.com
and you can donate to support my
campaign dude Tanner I'm not into people
plugging things like the Ross Tucker
football podcast randomly like that okay
we do things like that here on the DP
show no that's why I am curious though I
mean how much more reaction have you
gotten from your tweet to Gordon Hayward
to try to keep them then anything that
you're trying to do politically there's
a lot right and and there's a lot of
people who follow sports and it's more
fun and but look the direction of our
country is also a serious matter and at
the end of the day I think that right
now people are kind of correlating the
two but but when people go to vote
they're going to vote based on their
values in what direction they want the
country to go and it's more serious than
the fun conversation we're having right
now about Gordon Hayward Tanner good
luck to you and and I sincerely wish
good luck to the Utah Jazz as well we've
been talking about the NBA versus the
NFL and which has better free agency and
the thing I don't like about NBA free
agency is that if Gordon Hayward does
leave you know where does that leave
these teams that these guys leave to go
to these super teams that's what we've
been talking about so I hope he stays
we'll see what happens I know you're
giving it your best shot
thanks so much for coming on the show
thanks for having me on absolutely the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience